[Music]
why what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we have an episode today
where we're gonna be talking about
launching business and maximizing it for
success we are sitting down with the CEO
of think results marketing Jennifer
LeBlanc thank you for coming on to the
show thank you for inviting me it's a
pleasure to be here and you also are the
author of launching for revenue which as
I flipped through here I was very
impressed by the amount of different
aspects of business that you cover in
here which is really important in the
book what is what was really great like
I said was like this this example I mean
you even bookmark to here for me this
this redesign that you have of like a
logo mm-hmm just these very simple ways
that you can attract more eyeballs
decrease complexity increase
relatability
yeah these different things and then you
also are talking about things like the
the the simple message that when you
make a post on social media out of photo
exactly exactly these these are very
simple tips and you're really helping
out because what is it 90 92 percent of
high-tech companies fail high-tech
high-growth companies fail in two years
in two years years Wow yes and then you
know most products fail it's like 38 to
55% it depends on which research you
look at but anywhere from like 38% of
product launches or company launches to
92% failed so a large proportion of them
fail and as a scientist by training I
came to marketing with the idea that
everything can be studied and dissected
so okay how come some companies are
successful because clearly there's new
companies new products new services on
the market what's the difference between
the companies that get on the market and
those that fall by the wayside
I had to know the answer so I've spent
the last 20 years sort of stapling
myself to that and trying to understand
the difference and then I iced elated
that there's 10 elements and so that's
what's in that book and I want it to be
very tactical and practical so that
people could really just go through and
if they're working on their website they
can just dive into the website chapter
and there's examples of what to do and
what not to do right so that's really
important is not only what should you be
doing but what are some things you
should avoid and then at the end of each
chapter there's a self-assessment where
they can engage where they are within
each one of those elements it's meant to
be very much a workbook someone asked
you today if that's an audiobook and I'm
like it's not gonna work as an audiobook
like it's a pen and paper but yeah and
then and then they're doing these along
the way they're filling in sections
they're challenged like you were
teaching earlier they're looking at
themselves in the mirror objectives
exactly yeah exactly
because basically what we found through
our research whether it was our own
proprietary research or you know my own
studying of other companies and then our
clients and launches that were
successful not successful the difference
basically the companies that failed
missed on some simple things on one of
those 10 elements and there's small
things like you said and these yeah and
it can be the complexity of a logo not
enough social posting nine of community
engagement just team member that's right
the wrong role yeah so you may have it
may have been the right person at the
time and now your company has changed
and grown and that person not
necessarily the right role that are
gonna hold you back
yeah and you're constantly evaluating
that process team is really hard team is
really hurt as you grow things change
people change what may have been
comfortable and exciting for them two
years ago may not be now yes so that's
something to evaluate and check in with
your team yeah and then the hiring based
on values yes based on mission alignment
absolutely I'm a big believer in not
necessarily hiring on skills because
though it's gonna be taught but hiring
on you know the heart centeredness and
do they really have the vision that you
have are they
getting behind that vision do they have
the passion for what you're doing
because work can be tough sometimes
so skills I can teach passion integrity
you know ethics honesty I can't teach
those things they have to come to me
with those things this is what I'm
talking about hiring for my own team yes
yes
so these launch elements you have the
offering which is what your product
service or company is right so it could
be a product it could be a service it
could be the company itself when
companies are young typically that's
melded together right the product in the
company or the service and the company
are really the same thing and for larger
companies there's the company brand
there's product brands than they have
service brands and so it depends on you
know this can work for any of those
instances we call it the offering just
to make it broad and broad enough
exactly and then your positioning
positioning is number two so that's
really important because really if your
positioning is not working nothing else
is going to work and this is kind of the
differentiating factor how are you
positioning yourself in the market
understanding your persona is really key
to that so who I just did a workshop
this morning who are you really talking
to who are the decision-makers for your
company or your product or service and
then who are the influencers and do you
really understand them in the sense of
not only do you know what do they hear
what do they see what do they experience
but getting inside their heads so we
have an empathy map that we use to
really walk through that process just
sort of walk around the person and then
step inside their experience based on
what you know from kind of their outside
world that's uniquely understand
so you see yes you walk around them
meaning you're really trying to see them
from all these different ways all these
variables about do they hear from other
people what do they see what kind of
media do they consume what do they
listen to in terms of media it's all
psychometric analysis exactly knowing
that really clearly then allows you to
step inside okay and say okay now I
understand what their pains are and what
their gains are and how do we then drive
messages that are going to resonate with
that target audience yeah
and so then you have name logo website
the holy trilogy I call those yeah yeah
because they go together right yeah so
the name the logo and the website
typically are you know kind of a trilogy
package yep um you know naming is really
important I see a lot of mm-hmm really
big mistakes on naming and the logo is
key you know to the point you mentioned
earlier having a logo that's just really
clear and simple and people often ask a
logo to do way too much heavy liftings
my experience that's interesting that
you say that people are trying to cram
their whole their company whole brand
story into the logo yeah right and that
is partly the job of the name it's
partly the job of the logo it's partly
the job at the website it's partly the
job of the experience that you're
creating what is that experience you
want to create for your target market
and that people try to put all of that
into the logo and then it's got you know
17 elements and five different colors
it's just so complicated you can't even
read it yeah yeah so I see that a lot
yeah and the the the idea of
reductionism is actually kind of really
a good principle for a logo absent less
is more
we're looking for two three maybe four
elements in a logo yeah and that's one
of the things you know I've tried as
much as possible to sort of break this
whole process down into a science where
you can check the box
yeah all right there's also an art piece
of this that's Hardware sister you know
to still into that and again I was
talking about this morning to an
incubator that I was working with and I
said for example your logo can hit all
of the four check marks that we have in
our self-assessment and then I would
give it like a couple of bonus points
because if it's hitting all of those
executional points really well then it
needs a bonus set of points because then
the sum is typically greater than the
whole ain't the whole it's greater than
sum of the parts and so that's something
then there's an art to this as well
that's a little hard to steal into a
pocket yeah I judge on the art side of
things especially yeah okay and then the
the this other pillar I mean it seems as
though the name and the website go hand
here that there's there's got to be
something catchy about the name or the
website it's got to be something that
sticks in people's brains right and and
of course we've seen this throughout
history with different companies and
logos and websites but ones that kind of
have missions that are related to
providing humanity with some sort of
long-term sustainable utility value
something like that your are the ones
that Millennials and Gen Z's are really
latching on to and believing in more so
then than before because I mean we don't
want to see more of these companies that
are trying to take the attention economy
and you know take advantage of us or
seems a good thing yes a very good thing
like bring it on yeah yeah but it's like
yeah how do we maximize all the young
companies that are coming in the world
so you have sales strategy content
strategy and social strategy yeah so the
sales strategy is really making sure
that you understand mmm
how you will actually manage your leads
it's simple question but surprisingly
poorly executed from tiny to huge yes
and I've seen more than once a situation
where we've turned on the marketing pipe
and then all the leads come through and
everyone goes oh you know and they all
go sideways because there's no one to
catch them and manage those leads
exactly so really making sure that you
have a process to manage that lead
process and that you have trained your
sales force in the messaging I see that
a lot where marketing has their
messaging and sales is doing whatever
they're doing with the messaging so then
the customer is being sold something
that isn't actually what they get
delivered right so then you wonder why
you have a customer service problem yeah
later
yeah right so making sure that that
whole alignment is occurring so your
sales team is delivering the message you
want them to deliver
and then also on the backend of that
that you have a process for collecting
and capturing and managing those leads
in a time efficient manner again there's
a really simple stuff but you know it's
surprising how many not even just little
companies big companies which all remain
unnamed you know fail on these things
and so we do a lot of work with them on
that even just thinking about the the
funnel of of market marketing you know
you have any marketing messages you're
getting people coming into the funnel
what do you do with them at that point
it's so difficult there's so many
different customer relationship
management software's there's how do you
actually convert that lead into a closed
and how often do you message them how
how do you provide them with value with
the ideas you're providing them with
value you're not trying to sell them
something your exact vide them with
value so and then like you were saying
how the salespeople are aligned with
marketers and the sales providing
feedback to engineers and designers
exactly what's all putting that back
into the loop and saying here's what
customers are saying to us and that's
really important and that's often a
channel but it's not happening it's you
know it's product mark product design
they throw that over the fence to
marketing they throw it to sales you
know and it's all these isolated groups
right and then we wonder why customers
are like I don't understand I'm not
gonna buy cuz I understand mm-hmm you
know because as soon as you have that
sort of I don't get it customers they
forget it yeah yeah I'm thinking about
how many of those things we do wrong and
it's like all of them so we got a lot of
like I said I mean many people do and
and it's not that you need to get
there's another ten elements and they're
out of ten it comes to a hundred it's
nice math you don't have to get ten out
of ten on these to be successful you
just need to have most of them sort of
working you don't want to have yeah
three of them at a one or three yeah I
want to have most cement like six or
above and then at like you're saying
also at least if you're aware of all ten
yeah then when something pops up and you
know fizzles up then you can like
capture and be like oh I get it I know
what to do with it right if you can go
and upgrade yourself from a four to A
six in that category that's exactly I
mean the reason I wanted to get the book
out so I wanted to get this information
to as many people as possible because
I realized that we can isolate them we
can manage and we can measure these yes
so therefore let's get this out there so
that more companies can be successful
yes because it's it's painful to develop
a company you have ideas and visions and
they poured our heart and soul into it
and just from a you know cosmos
perspective that breaks my heart and the
idea that's trying to be realized
through that person is then dies and
right and it's sad because it's like you
you know you spent two years kind of
like raising a child right and totally
yeah it's totally I have a 20 year old
and I have my business and they are two
children and it's very much like raising
a child and I think when you are able to
pour that heart and soul into something
and bring it to the world that adds to
our world and when it does in you know
it takes some light out of the world and
so I've seen so many great technologies
fail because they were poorly marketed
or poorly positioned or missed on some
of these key elements and it wasn't that
it wasn't great technology that we
needed I mean my been dissenter to
technology because of where we are but
this could be said of almost any kind of
company and they don't make it to market
not because the product wasn't great and
that is a loss for all of us yeah yeah a
great product and one of these other
pillars is missing and the confusion
when somebody's trying to purchase it
and try to understand who you are exact
these last two are really important team
and funding so I mean nine team is
probably one of the most important
pillars and this whole mixture is we
were talking about the earlier having
values align mission or line people and
then also people want to transition to
different roles and all this different
stuffs and knowing about that knowing
went to higher funding I like to always
say this and I mean we're gonna open up
one of your decks that talks about the
amount of women that are in both venture
capital as well as entrepreneurship
startups and technology and you know
really interesting things how kevin
O'Leary is making greater returns on
female founders which is very
interesting so regarding funding though
it's it seems as though everyone and
their mothers trying to raise money and
it's become kind of crazy that everyone
and their mother what is it's like it's
like come on yeah you're like trying to
like make it understandable that it's
like everyone and their mother is
raising money everyone in the mother's
building apps are in Silicon Valley
absolutely yeah yeah in Silicon Valley
so now you know funding is something
that's to a to certain companies is
crucial for max right for maximizing
their growth and impact fast hiring
people fast at cetera um to other
companies it is almost like I don't need
to raise money absolutely it's not the
right path for everyone completely and
there's actually a lot of research
that's coming out about female founders
in particular that they whether by
choice or by forced into it and they
tend not to build businesses that really
need that kind of funding does that mean
that those businesses are not important
absolutely not I mean I was in an
incubator this morning with you know
nine companies and eleven women who are
founding important things that need to
bring brought out into the world not all
of those companies will require a
venture funding yep and frankly once you
say okay I'll accept your venture money
you have a target on your back so you
better go I want that venture money
because yeah you've got a timeline and
you got to meet those timelines and
there's a lot of pressure that you don't
have when you don't take venture funding
that's I like how you brought that up
it's this target on your back the
timeline the someone's like hey what am
I gonna get my money back and am I gonna
get my money back
that's a never ending refrain Brandi and
then on the on this another interesting
plus for not taking money is that it
almost lights the fire under your ass to
become profitable faster yes and that's
again to just speak about the female
founder experience and you know many of
the companies run by women tend to do
make money the old-fashioned way for
customers
as I joke about it don't fast UI
fashioned way you know instead of
getting VC money they make money for
customers concept in Silicon Valley
right so that is typically more common
in a female founder environment and so
and again it's just it's not necessarily
for everyone to do a VC raise and you
just need to be very aware of what
you're doing when you do a VC raise
because it's not it does not come
without strings absolutely yeah and
there's a lot of pressure you're gonna
like you know raise around raise around
raise around right yeah but it's not
always the best thing for every company
so we don't go into a lot of detail
about funding and that from that
perspective in this book in the next
book but um we do talk about the fact
that you know you need to make sure you
have to have enough money to make money
yep so if you're going to be trying to
ways away raise awareness you need to
have money to do that you need to have
that money ready and available it can't
be a promise from VC next year if you
want to get the launch time you know six
months from now you need to have that
money now so again I see that happen
more than once we're in a situation
where they haven't had the funding the
funding is coming you know and they're
kind of caught in this never-never-land
where they're trying to launch but they
don't have the money yet in their bank
account and so you can't get the right
thing set up
come on properly so that is something
where I have seen companies fail because
you know that sort of runway has had a
gap I forgot which famous venture
capitalist was it's a sails cures
everything
yes I don't know who that was but I love
that phrase because it's true so true
yes it's very true sells cures
everything so you know whatever you're
building into the world right now just
you know get people behind you that
believe in it and go and get that first
and and there's so many great options
now I mean crowdfunding is this amazing
tool because you raise awareness and
they're not just giving you likes on
Facebook they're actually paying for
your product right so you it's market
testing it's getting your early adopters
it's getting some cash
that gets you to like have enough money
to actually produce that product or
produce then whatever whatever through
right now on patreon love it yeah it's
what we're going through right now is
that there's people that believe in us
that chime in anywhere from five bucks a
month of 500 bucks a month that helped
us grow and then the same thing happens
on Kickstarter and IndieGoGo and with
all these companies that are doing
something in hardware or software or
whatever that people are you know paying
in two hundred fifty bucks for a product
and it's just for an idea right and then
they go and they take their couple
hundred thousand bucks they raise and
then they go and make it so you know
you're right it's never it's never
impossible there's so many different
ways to do it and it the only thing that
makes it impossible is you as me that
person that says I can't do that I can't
do that yeah and so there's definitely
many more options than there were even
ten years ago raising money so you know
there's a lot great angel investors out
there and who yeah they want their money
back but it's a little different than
working with a VCS they tend to be much
more you know investing their expertise
their connections and you so that's
something friends and family are always
out there that's always good to get but
you know certainly I'm a big fan of
crowd raising crowdfunding especially
for women and again the research is
showing that that is something that they
tend to be more effective at and then
that shows well when you actually do go
to raise money because you're like look
we have 500 people on IndieGoGo that
signed up for the product and I already
love it and yeah you know you get early
traction with money yep which is a
beautiful thing yep
I'm really happy that you wrote this and
I think again like you said the I mean
the the essence that you communicate to
me at the beginning is just this feeling
of lost potential that there's these 90
plus percent of businesses that are
failing high-tech businesses that are
failing by two years in what are we
missing as a civilization because we
didn't have really strong mentorship
really strong guidelines like this for
launching businesses successfully into
the world so I'd love that principle so
much about why you wrote that so and
this is so funny because your background
aquatic ecology yes is so interesting
that that you did the masters there and
then you got yourself into the last
fifteen years now of of marketing think
results marketing I'm working with Intel
Microsoft ventures so like maybe walk us
through a little bit about I'd love to
know how I got here
yeah yeah yeah give and give me
something really fun about the aquatic
ecology like because you obviously love
that and then you ended up moving into
the marketing and then what have been
some of the cool things that you've been
learning that of course you've wrote
into the book but also just from actual
physical interactions with these
different companies and what you've been
like learning from them I thought was
really interesting so just kind of to
sort of explain my transition which is a
bit seems a bit severe but and I
actually moved to the US now was it
twenty four years ago from where from
Canada from Canada yes I'm a dual
citizen now I became a citizen in 2000
that was very exciting but when I moved
here I thought well you know it's kind
of a new start and I I really loved
fieldwork I loved being on the boat even
though I was the only woman you know
with a bunch of guys swearing like a
sailor I had the worst potty mouth
because you have to to be credible with
the guys right you've got to swear just
like the guys I do yeah so um I love the
field work I could do field work all day
long if I if I was a trust fund baby
don't pay me I'll just do field work I
love that
but sitting in the lab counting samples
drove you nuts yeah because I'd count
five samples and I got the trend and
then I have 374 more to do before I can
publish my paper yeah yeah machines in
these machining that are helping in the
lab or so I was sitting at a microscope
County zoning maybe little little
rotifers and so finding stuff and I just
thought I I can't do this I know that I
could become a professor and then I have
grad students who do what I'm doing but
I don't think I can make it to that
point so then we moved here the US and I
thought well
you know I really love the communication
part I did a lot of communication with
farmers I know it sounds crazy but you
know water quality so their kids are
swimming at the beach right that water
comes from the stream that belongs to
ten different farmers farms and then
their cows are trampling the sides of
the banks causing silting which then
causes algae growth in the beach of the
lake so having just very basic
conversations that they're like wow I
had I hadn't connected that Yeah right
and so having those conversations and
then doing a lot of work
am i was working with potential
government and federal government in
Canada and talking about why some of the
research that we were doing that seemed
very esoteric and kind of you know like
why are we funding this explaining how
that might impact human health and so
that was something that I really enjoyed
doing and I thought well maybe I'll just
try this and see how it goes I had a
standing offer to work at dr. Charles
Goldman's lab in UC Davis he's the head
researcher for Lake Tahoe he's like God
my girlfriend still can't believe that I
turned it down I would we would love to
do like the show on some kind of crazy
kind of like psychology like that yeah
it's so great and so we did talk and I
did do some communications for him but
so I thought okay I have a plan B that's
like in the bag with like the top
researcher in the world to work in his
lab I'm gonna get myself six months to
try the scientific communications thing
and see if it works so by the end of the
six months I think I was telling you
earlier I was writing for Discovery
Channel online I was ghost writing for
local physicians in the paper I was
running the Davis food co-op newsletter
I was running to put a Creek newsletter
I'm like woah woah yeah like I'm so busy
I could hardly eat or sleep so I said I
think this is working
and then I moved to the Bay Area and
sort of fell into tech marketing and
loved it so but the one thing that I've
found is that having a science
background means that I can sit down
with engineers and talk about the most
arcane weird you know nitty-gritty
technical stuff and I can follow right
along with them because my brain is
trained to do that even though I'm
blonde and blue-eyed and I don't look
like
can handle it and I have had that
experience and where the scientists are
like whoa where did you come from when I
start asking the questions about their
research so it's actually been handy to
have that because I'm very comfortable
in deep technical discussions or you
know reading scientists you know
original papers and getting the gist of
what they're doing before we then write
about that technology and make it
explainable to the rest of the world
yep so I love doing that and so it's
really what we do now is is I know
you've done some of this work is taking
things that are really difficult to
explain and making them simple and
understandable to everyone else who's
not necessarily doing that all day long
yeah damn I wish that there was more
examples of of people's minds being
expanded to the awareness that like hey
I'm like judging you but holy [ __ ] you
know so much so it's like if once you'd
have the experience you like you kind of
stop judging people because you realize
that like this person I mean I know
nothing about them so I may as well just
ask them to question and then see how
they answer and then based on their
answer then I can see oh they are
scientifically literate or they are they
know more about marketing than I do or
they are from a different place in the
world that I suspected they were so you
got to ask a question instead of assume
and and I'm really happy that you bring
this up because like we'll dive into
this in this whole like I'm judging
somebody without even knowing anything
about them but I'm really happy that you
also mentioned this kind of like you
know your your background going through
the going through the lab work going
through the the the tons of different
journals and publications that you're
working on knowing how to make things
are relatable and then jumping in a high
tech it was like hey like I'm keeping up
with engineers I'm keeping up a
scientist and then I'm able to help them
disseminate in relatable ways totally
what we care about as well it's really
interesting there's this there'll be
some interesting collabs as we go on and
both with the people that we feature to
you know help with think results
marketing but also just like as we get
to wanting to get to sports stadiums we
need to figure out how to actually
I love that do that and get there I mean
yeah I love it so let's you know let's
pull up actually before that let's ask
you quick about as you've worked with
like Microsoft ventures in Intel like
what have been some of these like really
interesting takeaways that you think
would be important to share I think
especially for my my startups you know
they always think that the larger
companies have endless resources and
they do when they don't and you know in
terms of intellectual resources yeah
they have in those resources but you
know every company no matter what their
size has a limited budget limited time
and limited resources to do what they
need to do it's just that when you work
with Intel or Microsoft or s AP or any
large company they have a much bigger
market that they need to attack so they
need a much larger budget to do that it
seems humongous to my startups but
should the size of the budget the
proportion is about the same so it's
still not enough
and so you still have to make decisions
about how are you gonna spend your
marketing dollars in a way that really
preserves your time your energy your
money and your resources yeah no matter
who you are and I think that is
something that kind of stuns my startups
when I work with them they're like oh
well you know if we had the money yes if
you had the money of Intel to work on
your little market you'd be fine yeah
but Intel has this massive market that
they need to cover with their budget and
percentage-wise is about the same as
what you have yep so you know don't
think that any company is has unlimited
resources other than they have amazing
amounts of brainpower and big companies
but then the problem is how do you
access that so I worked with a company
and Microsoft ventures that just got
acquired by workday rally team and their
whole thing was many large companies
hire people like us and but there's
actually that experience and expertise
internally but they don't know how to
find it so like essentially a LinkedIn
for finding people inside your own
company
because that's the difficulty they do
have those resources but they don't know
how to tap it yeah we're had to find
those people yeah it's like once you
have a couple thousand people then how
do you figure not leave its track and
track of them all like what they do you
know because I remember when I was at
PeopleSoft years ago we started
basically a talent management and you
know software piece and so we had to
fill out this form about things that we
knew how to do and of course you know
this was my job and I listed out okay I
can do you know that had a checkbox and
then there were some kind of open fields
and so I listed sort of all of these
things that I knew how to do that you
know we're not in my job and my boss was
like holy cow
and I'm like I just check the box and I
think that was probably true for a lot
of people was you know people know you
for doing the job that you do but they
don't know that you have these other
things which could be like I'm awesome
at you know playing guitar so like next
time we have an employee event let me
come in and do a concert hello believe
it could be something that's not
necessarily work-related but if it's
never been discussed if you're kind of
introverted you may not necessarily be
shouting from the rooftops I have these
17 other skills yes and so that's one of
the problems with the companies they
have endless resources but they don't
know who they are where they are how to
find them how to leverage that so that's
the problem
that's such a good example you know here
you know here's you you know talking in
front of people
and all these people they're not just
one-trick ponies this isn't just someone
that can only do one thing you know
these are people that understand other
things as well and if something
dimensional people imagine that won't
imagine that and then if we can figure
out how to unleash their skill sets like
you even said just the symbol eyes like
play the guitar at the company gathering
right like because you know how to do
that like let's do it and then somebody
will be like remember that time that you
played the guitar like that was amazing
whatever so you're unleashing people's
full potentials in different domains and
I like how you mentioned that I like how
you mentioned the the proportionate
marketing budgets I think that was
really interesting as well because you
know we just have you know
emulation we just have a much smaller
market right now our marketing budget is
pretty much nothing and but you know
ideally we have this massive market but
we don't because we don't yet know how
to like fully tap into that and leverage
marketing dollars like maybe a company
like Intel does at this point so it's
it's it's actually really good that you
teach us about that so ok let's let's
bring let's bring this up because you
know this is this is a deck that that
you've been kind of teaching and we're
gonna get this up on our NDI connection
Ronnie you got it right and that cool
changing tides this is changing tides
this is when you talk about the changing
tides I'm teaching that I'm saying yes
so so let's quickly talk about changing
tides because this books gonna be
released in oh so we have a we have a my
hand right yeah yeah well I was doing
both books at the same time which was
making me primarily crazy and psychotic
yeah so well explain this story how we
ended up with this thank you both we
have pictures of cool that's cute though
and cool so yeah powerful strategies for
female founders yes
and so this is this is gonna be released
in a couple months and you know we have
the link in the bio for launching for
revenue and changing tides is gonna be
coming out soon and a lot of what you
are teaching in here is it really just
the maximizing the success of the female
founders and how we're just making a
slow transition and there's so many
skill sets that are that women know how
to tap into about energy and about
empathy and about feeling and all these
different things that that men are not
think this is just this isn't meant to
be like some binary sort of like only
this and already that thing is yeah it's
just you know it's just typically men
are not trained in those skills yeah
it's not that they can't do them they're
just typically not socially trained
skills yeah you know and there's
obviously a continuum you know I've been
told more than once that I have you know
bigger balls and some men and I said
well that says more about you than it
does about me you think you think I do
you think would win in a scrap between
you and I who wouldn't in a scrap I
think you think you can kick my ass when
it comes intellectual theft you know
might fart out but physical and Jen I'd
that's that's not Hong joke I asked
people that I'm sorry Dec what else yeah
yeah yeah so here's a mock of le quote
yeah I gave us this morning to the the
incubator group and um I think he had a
lot of good things to say and it's also
a bit of a private nod to my grandmother
who was incredibly Machiavellian yeah
grandmother was oh yeah if it was about
the family totally did not matter how
she got there as long as she predicted
the family yeah yeah
she had no morals when it came to the
rest of the world damn protecting us
damn boy that's all 15 minutes I'm uh
Thank You Ronnie she was she was a
character because this is like that's a
great quote protection of genetic
lineage so interesting yeah yeah yeah
that's another story but I love this
quote because this really sums up I mean
we work a lot with companies who are
launching for the first time they're
moving into new markets there's just a
lot of unknown there's a lot of fear
there's a lot of change management that
has to happen and so when I read this I
was like yes that is what we do and that
is exactly it just captures the whole
spirit of be of the moment when you're
trying to launch a new company because
we always run into this and that's my
next book after this one which is half
written is what happens when you hit the
wall and a watch because invariably in
every launch at some point the CEO
typically or someone else's
go the fear comes sometimes walls happen
everyday
right but they're little walls right but
there's usually a big one at some point
when there's the hole like maybe we
shouldn't do this launch and like this
whole sort of self-doubt starts to
happen usually it's just about as the
vision starts to really take hold you
got to drive a [ __ ] tank through that
wall right it's very very predictable
when this is gonna happen and so that's
why I ended up doing neuro-linguistic
programming coaching because now I
realize I have to like help my clients
through that wall and then your families
like don't take the risk just take the
job get a job get a job get a real job
my other grandmother used to say to me
all the time so when are you gonna get a
real job again honey yeah yeah I have
one yeah it's a real job I myself did
not understand that you know I left you
know - fantastic companies you know just
start think results and she just thought
that was insane like don't get a normal
job honey so so do you know what else
this reminds me of was the the quotes
about that though when you look at the
world the people that are comfortable
with the world they're not the ones that
make change the ones that want to
challenge the status quo are the ones
crazy enough to believe in them are the
ones that take this and go and do it and
you got to be able to take the risk and
to make this new order of things so
right okay so jumping into like okay so
2% 2% of VC funding goes to women
damn it is this from 2018 7 2017 the new
numbers - come on October but I'm not
expecting it to be much higher Wow
maybe a little I mean it needs to be
significantly higher obviously now that
said there are not as many female
founders which is another problem that's
8% 17% Oh founders are female okay okay
and a mattress enter a venture
capitalist and I think it's 9 percent
now are venture capitalists okay and
that are female and 17 percent are
founders at least that's a female that's
a high way higher than 2% right so you
know clearly because people say oh well
how many people you know how much
percentage of companies are run by women
yeah well it's not 2 percentage 17 which
is not great I mean we need
to make that better yes there's a lot of
factors that conspire to keep women out
of the system yeah and so that's
something that I'm really passionate
about instead of yep happened through
you know kind of through research but
also just you know last summer we know
when the justin callback and dave
McClure stories came out I was actually
on a writing retreat powering through
seven chapters of that book and these
stories came out I was supposed to be
offline but I was still kind of
following things and these stories came
out and I felt like somebody had ripped
a band-aid off my arm and the blood
would not stop flowing I don't know
exactly what it was but I was like I can
no longer remain silent about what I
know is going on in Silicon Valley what
I know happened to me to call these of
mine and the things that I heard from
female founders you know at various
companies I've worked with over the
years
and I started to dig into the research
and it was even worse than I thought and
I think the the path to rehabilitation
is the thing that we highlight the most
here as we talk about these things it's
like there have been incredibly crappy
things that have happened from thousands
of years ago from hundreds years ago and
even from a decade or a couple years ago
and it's like how do we rehabilitate we
have we have a we have PTSD societal
PTSD that we're fixing right now and I'm
happy that were only unpacking more of
the conversations and moving for
rehabilitation right so it was really
before the me2 movement that I started
writing changing tides and that's when I
decided I had to do a second book while
I was writing another book and then me
too happens and that has you know been a
really positive thing to really raise
the awareness I think a lot of men even
you know men that I know including my my
husband who is amazing and who's very
aware he was stunned he he knew my
experiences but didn't really realize
how much women spend their lives sort of
watching over their shoulders and then
the the other extreme the the like
looking over the shoulders things very
[ __ ] and needs to beat
changed societally needs to be changed
just a much more gentle loving caring
approach to dynamics between people but
then also this like other side of the
story is also messed up like Mike Pence
doesn't take meetings with women alone
anymore like things like that I'm like
come on we got to figure this out
because this is if we got to be able to
have like you you can come on to our
show without feeling right exactly we
got to figure out how to you need to be
not afraid to have a woman on your show
because you know she might say something
yeah so so here so here were again we're
indicating the amount of female founded
companies that are you know right so
it's the little blue it's hard to see in
small yeah it's slowly increasing but
yeah it's it's a really time to rock it
that up because I think that once we
rock it that up we're gonna see some
interesting things unfold like you know
women being hired and agreeableness than
men being more disagreeable it's like
what would a company look like that
focus on a value of like empathy and a
focus on these different sort of values
of camaraderie that are slightly
different than you do here a bomb I
think was last week he said I think we
need to have women and run things around
here because I'm really kind of done
yeah that's kind of funny we need to
work together I don't know that we need
to just come together we can't just
completely give women you know the we
have to be careful well I just want yeah
yeah and then and then also just like
seeing what you know the iran-us not
that communication that just happened
it's like what would it look like if we
were to just you know meditate a bit
more and just you know slow down and be
like you know objectively how can we
work better together across the earth
because this yelling at each other not
working yeah and it's a small rock and
we definitely don't want to see any
World War 3 [ __ ] happen so yeah yeah
so what's four point four percent so
four point four percent I believe that
is the value of yeah this is the total
number so number of deals by gender and
it's kind of a rather than that we're
looking to two percent so yes number of
deals and then the next one this five
Millions
women tend to get this is the kind of
comparative value of deal size so women
tend to get a little bit over five
million dollars per deal and men get a
little bit under or male that company's
a little under 12 million dollars so
that's quite a difference and that's a
that's like a series a round or what
does that be ground it's just overall
kind of the total value of the amount of
deals kind of on average so a lot of
this is very average okay
okay got it so yeah they had didn't
break it down I don't think by what
series you know you can you can do some
of those cuts but this didn't do that
then this is the percentage that are
venture capitalist and the percentage
that are yes in founders yes that has
gone up somewhat so with female founders
so then this actually has I think
there's a hundred in this on the actual
yeah the actual research has all of them
but basically how which firms have the
most female partner so this was a
presentation that I gave to the Google
female founders some it was the keynote
march and so really I was trying to give
them information right yeah so you want
to be looking at the firm's that have
more female founders if you're trying to
get funding it's not that men don't you
know tend to give well they don't but it
it's not that you men won't give you
money but you're more likely to get
money if you're gonna go to a female VC
you're more likely to get money if you
go to a corporate VC you're more likely
to get money if you work with an
accelerator that has female partners
they're kind of let's make these things
easy because a lot of things for a
minute were just that much harder we
don't have the mentorship we don't have
the examples we don't have the support
along the way that men have typically
gotten and so this was trying to sort of
level that playing field for them and
saying here's some tips to make your
sailing just a little bit smoother which
might make the difference between you
saying I can't do this anymore
yeah and staying in business which is
tough yep for anyone but it's doubly
tough yeah for for women and I can't
remember what it's my name is for sure
these are kind of getting into the
details I think some of these are things
like new partners new firms so most of
the many of the new firms tend to be
more female friendly they tend to more
likely be founded by a woman
then there's also some good research
which I think was a prior slide about
corporate VCS tend to be more female
friendly and probably because they're
coming out of sort of an HR environment
that's one of the challenges with female
founders is that they're working in this
very much Wild West there is absolutely
no protection for a female founder hey
let's meet at the bar and you know we'll
talk about your business and then you
get there and it's not what it's about
right there's no one to go to there's no
protection and I think that's probably
why sometimes the corporate VCS tend to
be mmm a little better with female
founders intended baby you know put more
money into female founders so and then
new firms there's a big increase in
female founders female founded companies
that's been happening as well so that's
nice this is really super important
research from Harvard Business Review
basically was just like this story still
so stuck in my head about just going out
to talk about a business oh I can't tell
you how many times that's happened just
come on like make it more you know make
it more clear like what the intentions
are and you know we had this discussion
on one of the female founder groups I'm
on Facebook and together with several
other females there's like 6,000 female
founders on there but it's like a little
bit primordial also this feeling that's
like yeah like okay well I am both
attract to the business that you're
doing but also to you maybe in like
maybe if I said it in a way that was a
little bit you know just you know
straightforward like hey you know maybe
I'd be interested in going on a date
sometime in life and just see what the
other person has to say and don't be
pushy like no okay great like I'll still
be willing to you know talk to you about
business and stuff but the problem is in
that situation there's an extreme power
dynamic because you've got typically a
male VC who has a lot of money and a lot
of power or whether or not that business
is successful yeah and then you've got a
female founder who doesn't have money
who doesn't have power who really needs
this money in power yes make her vision
succeed so it's a very imbalance dynamic
and whenever you have a really imbalance
dynamic there's your rest
really high likelihood there's going to
be something going wrong it's very good
point yeah so this is super important
research and I I do this as an exercise
of my female founders so basically the
research showed that VCS tend to ask
male founders questions about promotion
like what's your vision for the company
how are you going to acquire customers
kind of painting a big picture then they
tend to ask women prevention questions
what are you gonna do to reduce customer
churn how are you gonna defend against
the competition why because that's what
we tend to do so the problem with this
is that the researchers then went on to
study these founders and sort of their
raises over the next couple of years and
kind of corrected for size of company
experience of founders all those things
and they found that the for every
prevention-oriented question that was
asked they went on to raise 3.8 million
dollars less per question
damn per question that's a significant
difference so promotions much more yes
yeah and because we are humans there's
good news in this research and because
we are humans we tend to answer
questions as they're asked right our
mirror neurons say if you ask me a
promotion question I'm going to give you
a promotion answer versus a prevention
right but I can also be paired together
as well because it's important to know
so yes if you ask if a female found a
prevention question and she does what
entrepreneurs do and doesn't do what's
expected and turns it around into
promotion orange and answer and says yes
we're concerned about customer churn but
let me talk about how we're going to
gain customers to make sure that there's
a minimal issue in it she will go on to
raise 7.9 million dollars more per
question yeah that's great yeah so it's
like the mindset the ability transition
to a promotional answer right can I want
to make sure that we that we highlight
this at least on here this is really
important it's like we have these very
powerful female founders but you know
billion dollar valuations is just really
amazing to see this stitch fix how's
task
Rent the Runway these are all very
popular companies today and this is this
is awesome and there's a hole and when I
when I initially saw this I was like wow
just wait and tell more of the Jen Sears
there is and there is there's a whole
you know cohort behind these four and
and there's a lot of talk about in the
next three to five years seeing several
you know billion-dollar multi-billion
dollar companies run by women coming out
helia and it's good seeing like 18 19
year olds that are like coming up that
are really powerful as well back so this
was really important as well like Kevin
O'Leary's getting better returns with
female founders which is very
interesting it's like I wonder how much
venture capital is actually experiencing
higher returns female founders and why
why is it many of them are they're not
always talking about data but I know one
of my contributors for changing tides is
Susanna Fletcher from Stanford startx
which is basically the Stanford Thank
You Bader and so she's track data and
it's definitely seeing the female
founded companies have better
survivability they tend to raise more
money which is interesting because
that's kind of not typical data and they
tend to meet they're not like reinforces
this exactly and so you know the
question becomes you know not only is
this a social issue this is a business
issue why is money not following money
if it makes good business sense to
invest in women then why are we not
doing it yeah I don't really enter to
figure out the business the numbers
behind it and let's explore this more
yeah and there's a ton of research that
talked about in the book yeah about the
fact that there's actually plenty of
business evidence that having women and
you know this has certainly been shown
in the corporate world if for example
you have women a gender diverse board a
gender diverse c-level t-yong 15%
you know increases in your in your
returns if you have a gender diverse and
a racially diverse and ethnically
diverse that's 35 percent so I want more
of that research can you send me that
research I want to I want to identify
more that research when we initially
talk to
Pearson in February we were having an
in-depth conversation with him about the
nuance behind all of the all of this
that oh is it possible that a aboard
that that brings on people from
different ethnicities from around the
world they have different philosophies
maybe about honk company should be run
they maybe have different sorts of
strategies for marketing and
monetization they know how to hit the
hearts of different people across the
world all this different kind of stuff
and you know Jordan was very clear that
like no there's no research on that and
so now McKenzie I want to I want to want
to take some of this with Kinsey
research I don't understand it more pass
it along to him unpack it more wire
female founders getting higher returns
how many of them are exciting stuff to
figure out just a couple quick questions
on the way out that we typically like to
ask on the show Jen do you think we're
alone in the cosmos absolutely not tell
us a little more like I just
biologically speaking it just can't be
it doesn't make sense to me as a
scientist that we are the only thinking
life-form it's just the odds are not
there I don't I don't see how that's
possible and then do you think that wait
but I can't wait either I know we got a
James Webb Space Telescope coming up
we've got all these cool things that
we're glad to see and then how about we
just learned about Louvre War move war
that's also it's in a kind of like multi
decade plan of of NASA but it's gonna
really be able to image the atmospheric
compositions of these exoplanets to be
like look there's oxygen and carbon and
water and yeah exactly
so do you think that this could be a
simulation thank you yeah why there's
times in my life when I'm like I just
feel like it's
it's just not I'm not running the show
yeah I just have that feeling of you've
lost world sometimes like very
determined and I think mm-hmm am I
really in charge here yeah your
microbiome is more in charge sometimes
Hey absolutely you don't even you didn't
even think about going over to the
fridge you just magically appeared I
exit the fridge right so yeah I
definitely it has occurred to me I know
that sounds crazy but it has occurred to
me you know but we just sort of keep
going as if we are really in charge of
our lives right yeah more fun that way
I'm glad I'm glad that you're very you
know you've thought about it more than
just the the classic kind of oh no
there's no way you know that's that's a
classic answer you know that we get and
it's it's great to you know be able to
actually unpack some more of the truth
behind the lack of free will that we
experience at times yeah because is it
really you that is you know that is
walking on the beach and you see you
know if you're a woman and you see a
like a very attractive man without a
shirt on is that really you that it's
coming up with this thought of like oh
he's so hot or she's so hot or whatever
or is that more like this primordial
sense within you that yeah you can't
even control you're just physically
attractive and I don't know how much of
that is biological and how much is that
as someone you know kind of running me
but there definitely are times when I
feel like wow I am really not in charge
here like something else is in charge
I'm not sure what it is yeah something
else is looking at the menu there's two
options it's like how did I pick that
option how did I pick that pair of jeans
how did I really just like still unpack
further athlete what do you think's last
question what do you thinks the most
beautiful thing in the world love and
unpack that more why I think it's the
most you know as a scientist this is
kind of shocking to me but um you know
as I've gotten older I've mellowed and
so I think that that is such a powerful
force I think that when you have those
moments of you know and I mean love and
the bigger sense it doesn't necessarily
mean kind of you know between
you know spouses but you know loving
your work you know loving the experience
of doing this loving the earth there's
all kinds of moments when you when you
forget who you are and you're just in
that connection to the bigger world and
I think for me that's definition of love
and I mean that's what I love to do with
my clients is get them to that point
where they see something bigger and I
love that and so that is to me the most
beautiful thing in the world is just
that moment of possibility and that
could be in a you know a romantic
relationship it could be with work but
it's that brief moment when we just feel
like we've just touched the universe to
me that's with like a love or
romantically with them maybe a parent or
a ideas idea I like that work your your
focus you know when you get in that flow
that's to me that's love your topic yeah
it's ethereal yeah so subtle and so so
deeply kind of like transcendent of just
this body exactly else so to me that's
the most beautiful thing at that moment
let me feel connected to the universe
and to me that's what love is Jen
LeBlanc what a pleasure this has been
thank you very much for coming on to the
show yeah I'm glad you had a good time
thanks thank you so much for coming on
and for all those think results
marketing.com the links and the bio go
check it out
also definitely check out launching for
revenue the links in the bio as well
really think about how we can maximize
more of these ideas into the world
like can we follow awesome guidelines
and procedures and also expand ourselves
even past those as well but can we
really take these principles and apply
them to maximizing your business success
so if you guys had a good time going to
share with two other people what you
learn tell them about it have them go to
start talking about it and let's execute
more of these don't just consume go
create this content go make videos go
make blog posts go start businesses go
and make with this join us
subscribe comment below
we'd love to start a community talking
about things like this also join us on
patreon help us continue supporting and
growing this endeavor thank you everyone
for tuning in thanks to Ron our director
and producer much love everybody
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]